this is my favorite protest shirt it
says protect your people we made it in
the basement of our Community Center
I've worn it at rallies at protests and
marches at candlelight vigils with
families who have lost loved ones to
police violence I've seen how this ethic
of community organizing has been able to
change arresting practices hold
individual officers accountable and
allow families to feel strong and
supported in the darkest moments of
their lives but when a family would come
to our Center and say my loved one got
arrested what can we do we didn't know
how to translate the power of community
organizing that we saw on the streets
into the courts we figured we're not
lawyers and so that's not our arena to
make change and so despite our belief in
collective action we would allow people
that we cared about to go to court alone
nine out of ten times and this is true
nationally they couldn't afford their
own attorney and so they'd have a public
defender who is doing heroic work but
was often under-resourced and stretched
bare with too many cases they would face
prosecutors aiming for high conviction
rates mandatory minimum sentences and
racial bias baked into every stage of
the process and so facing those odds
stripped away from the power of
community unsure how to navigate the
courts over 90% of people that face a
criminal charge in this country will
take a plea deal meaning they'll never
have their fabled day in court that we
talk about in television shows and in
movies and this is the untold part of
the story of mass incarceration in
America how we became the largest jailer
in the world over 2 million people
currently incarcerated in this country
and projections that say one out of
three black men will see the inside of a
prison cell at some point in their life
on this trajectory but we have a
solution
we decided to be irreverent to this idea
that only lawyers can impact the courts
and to penetrate the judicial system
with the power intellect and ingenuity
of community organizing we call the
approach participatory defense
it's a methodology for families and
communities who has loved ones are
facing charges and how they could impact
the outcome of those cases and transform
the landscape of power in the courts how
it works is families whose loved ones
are facing criminal charges will come to
a weekly meeting and it's half
support-group half strategic planning
session and they'll build a community
out of what otherwise would be an
isolating and lonely experience and
they'll sit in a circle and write the
names of their loved ones on a board who
they're there to support and
collectively the group will find out
ways to tangibly and tactically impact
the outcome of that case they'll review
police reports to find out
inconsistencies they'll find areas that
requires more investigation by the
defense attorney and they'll go to court
with each other for the emotional
support but also so that the judge knows
that the person standing before them is
part of a larger community that is
invested in their well-being and success
and the results have been remarkable
we've seen charges get dismissed
sentences significantly reduced
acquittals one at trial and sometimes it
has been literally life-saving like in
the case of Ramon Vasquez father of two
family man truck driver and so on who
was wrongfully charged with the
gang-related murder he was totally
innocent of but was facing a life
sentence
Ramon's family came to those meetings
shortly after his arrest and his
detention and they worked the model and
through their hard work they found major
contradictions in the case gaping holes
in the investigation and was able to
disprove dangerous assumptions by the
detectives like that the Red Hat that
they found when they raided his home
somehow affiliated him to a gang
lifestyle through their photos and the
records they're able to prove that the
Red Hat was from his son's little league
team that Ramone coached on the weekends
and they produced independent
information that proved that Ramone was
on the other side of town at the time of
the alleged incident through their phone
records and receipts from the stores
that they attended after seven long
months of hard work from the family
Ramone staying strong inside jail they
were able to get the charge dismissed
and they brought Ramone home to live the
life that he should have been living all
along and with each new case the
families identified new ways to flex the
knowledge of the community to have
impact on the court system we would go
to a lot of sentencing hearings and when
we would leave the sentencing hearing
and on the walk back to the parking lot
after someone's loved one just got sent
to prison
the most common refrain we would hear
wasn't so much I hate that judge or I
wish we had a new lawyer what they would
say was I wish they knew him like we
know and so we developed tools and
vehicles for families to tell the fuller
story of the loved one so they would be
understood as more than just a case file
they started making what we call social
biography packets which is families
making a compilation of photos and
certificates and letters that show past
challenges and hardships and
accomplishments and future prospects and
opportunities and the social biography
videos were working so well in the
courts that we evolved it into social
biography videos
ten-minute many documentaries which were
interviews of people in their homes and
at their churches and at their workplace
explaining who the person was in the
backdrop of their lives and it was a way
for us to dissolve the walls of the
court temporarily and through the power
of video bring the judge out of the
court and into the community so that
they would be able to understand the
fuller context of someone's life that
they're deciding the fate of one of the
first social biography projects that
came out of our camp was by Carnell he
had come to the meetings because he had
pled to a low-level drug charge and
after years of sobriety got arrested for
this one drug possession charge but he
was facing a five-year prison sentence
because of the sentencing schemes in
California we knew him primarily as a
dad he'd bring his daughters to the
meetings and then play with them at the
park across the street and he said look
I could do the time but if I go in
they're gonna take my girls and so we
gave him a camera and said just take
pictures of what's like being a father
and so he took pictures of making
breakfast for his daughters and taking
him to school
take him to after-school programs and
doing homework and it became this photo
essay that he turned into his lawyer who
used at the sentencing hearing and that
judge who originally indicated a
five-year prison sentence understood
Carnell in a whole new way and he
converted that five-year prison sentence
into a six-month outpatient program so
that Carnell could be with his daughters
his girls would have a father in their
life and Carnell could get the treatment
that he was actually seeking we have one
ceremony of sorts that we use in
participatory defense and I told you
earlier that when families come to the
meetings they write the names of their
loved ones on the board and those are
names that we all get to know weekend
week out through the stories of the
family and we're rooting for and praying
for and hoping for and when we win a
case when we get a sentence
reduced or a charge dropped or we went
in acquittal that person who's been a
name on the board comes to the meeting
and when their name comes up they're
given an eraser and they walk over to
the board and they erase their name and
it sounds simple but it is a spiritual
experience
and people are applauding and they're
crying and for the families that are
just starting that journey and are
sitting in the back of the room for them
to know that there's a finish line that
one day they too might be able to bring
their loved one home that they could
erase the name is profoundly inspiring
we're training organizations all over
the country now in participatory defense
and we have a national network of over
20 cities and it's a church in
Pennsylvania it's a parent's association
in Tennessee it's a Youth Center in Los
Angeles and the latest city that we just
added to the national network to grow
and deepen this practice is Philadelphia
they literally just started their first
weekly participatory defense meeting
last week and the person that we brought
from California to Philadelphia to share
their testimony to inspire them to know
what's possible was Ramon Vasquez who
went from sitting in a jail in Santa
Clara County California to inspiring a
community about what's possible through
the perseverance of community across the
country and with all the hubs we still
use one metric that we invented it's
called time saved it's a saying that we
actually still say at weekly meetings
and what we say when a family comes in
meeting for the first time is if you do
nothing
the system is designed to give your
loved one time served that's the
language the system uses to quantify
time of incarceration but if you engage
if you participate you can turn time
served into time saved
that's them home with you living the
life they should be living
so Carnell for example would represent
five years of time safe so when we
totaled our time saved numbers from all
the different participant ory defense up
through their work in the meetings and
at court and making social biography
videos and packets we had four thousand
two hundred and eighteen years of time
saved from incarceration that is parents
in children's lives young people going
to college instead of prison we're
ending generational cycles of suffering
and when you consider in my home state
of California it costs sixty thousand
dollars to house someone in the
California prison system that means that
these families are saving their states a
ton of money I'm not a mathematician I
haven't done the numbers but that is
money and resources that can be
reallocated to mental health services to
drug treatment programs to education and
we're now wearing this shirt in courts
all across the country and people are
wearing this shirt because they want the
immediacy of protecting their people in
the courtroom but what we're telling
them is as practitioners they're
building a new field a new movement that
is going to forever change the way
justice is understood in this country
thank you
[Applause]